you know life is much easier when you're
nice and you're not for many people that
are nice are afraid to be nice are
afraid to show kindness because they
think that it's going to make them look
weak being nice just makes life so much
easier
rise and shine it's an espresso time
what's up believe nation it's Evan I
believe in you and this channel is
designed to be a part of your daily
success routine so let's start your day
off right together grab your coffee and
sip on today's message be nice over to
you Dwayne Johnson also if you want to
know what Dwayne Johnson and other
successful entrepreneurs have to say
about building unstoppable confidence
check out my 250 for confidence series
where every day for the next 254 days I
will send you a morning video for free
to help you build your confidence the
link to join is in the description below
my call time is at 7 then you back your
clock up for hours and then that's when
I get up when it comes to kindness or
being nice to - it's very very easy for
me I heard something when I was 15 years
old I'll never forget it and this was at
a time where we were struggling to pay
the rent and living paycheck to paycheck
and the quote that I heard was it's nice
to be important but it's more important
to be nice and I remember hearing that I
thought man I hope one day maybe fingers
crossed
God willing universe willing whatever
that I'm considered important that it
would matter if I'm nice to people so
yeah it's very very easy and also you
know life is much easier when you're
nice and you're not for nice guys and
gals don't finish last
you can operate with integrity fairness
good intentions and still be firm in
your beliefs if you operate like this
you will win what matters is that you
own yourself that you go all-in on the
thing that makes you different if your
thing is kindness then be a beacon of
kindness many people that are nice are
afraid to be nice
are afraid to show kindness because they
think that it's going to make them look
weak and that hedge is why you won't win
because you're pretending to be someone
you're not you have to go all in on you
I'm reminded of my recent trip to LA
where I went there and I spent 4 days in
an event and I was speaking and I spent
the whole time in the lobby and I woke
up at 7:30 went to the lobby started
helping entrepreneurs and I looked up
and it was time for dinner and I went
out grab a sub came back and sort of
helping entrepreneurs and it was until
2:30 in the morning with the bed and I
rinsed and repeat that for four days I
went to three speaking gigs my own Gary
bees and derral eves who put on the
event and the rest of the time I spent
in the lobby helping people and I turned
down brakes and I turned down VIP events
because I loved being in the room
helping entrepreneurs one-on-one it made
me come alive I was the only speaker
doing it not because I'm better than
anybody else but because that's that's
what I love to do that's what I wanted
to do I had a fever the whole time
it was not healthy for me I didn't sleep
enough and I came home and got sick and
crashed but I was going all-in on me and
the number one comment that I got from
people was that Evan you've gotten so
much traction on YouTube you've got all
these subscribers you're you're a big
fish now and it's crazy how you're
spending time in the room just helping
people were just getting started and
that comment came up with almost every
person that I met with over the four
days and I was I was pissed I was really
upset about that because I don't know
why kindness and why humbleness and why
contribution isn't more cool like why
more people aren't doing it and and I
set the secret intention with myself
that I want to come back to the same
event with ten million subscribers next
year and do the exact same thing all
over again to show kindness and
humbleness and help people and spend the
entire time not going to the fancy
parties but helping the people are just
getting started in the lobby all day for
four days and not sleep and I think
whenever it is that you staying for
whatever isn't you believe in whatever
you feel might be a perceived weakness
it's actually the thing that will make
people connect with you better people
say well you have to be authentic you
have to be authentic well how do you be
authentic what does it even look like
what does that mean how do I tactically
do it you share the thing that you're
most afraid of sharing the thing that
you are most afraid of being judged for
is the thing that you need to share
that's how people will connect with you
if you are perfect nobody wants to learn
from you people don't want to learn from
the perfect person because they think
well you're perfect I'm not perfect so I
can't do that same thing that you did
you have to show me the chinks in your
armor you have to show me how you are
afraid you have to show me the thing
that you stand for and you believe in
and you'll put yourself out there for
and be judged for people judge me for
not going to the VIP events they'll
judge you for it and you do it anyway
and you share that and that's what makes
some people connect with you I don't
make other people say this person is
stupid that's why you get judged for it
but if you play life so vanilla and
boring that you don't make any anybody
upset or happy you'll never grow your
business people will never connect with
you as a human so when you go off and
you do the thing that you would be
judged for you become a beacon for that
you start attracting people who love
that and you give permission to other
people to also go off and do that same
thing you will inspire other people
through the thing that you're most
vulnerable and afraid to share by
sharing it by being a voice for it you
will inspire other people who are
watching you who will then take
courageous bold steps in that same
direction as well and so if you want to
be a beacon of kindness then you need to
spread more kindness yourself then you
need to stop being afraid of being weak
being seen as incompetent being seen as
somebody who doesn't have strength or
power and the more you stand up and do
that it'll not only help you and your
growth it'll help you accomplish your
mission and your goals but I'll inspire
other people to come after you and say
wow look at what you're doing look at
what that person is doing I want to do
it too so I'm gonna give you the own
your life formula the 3-step process
that you need to take to own your life
step number one what are you afraid to
show weakness in what is the thing
you're afraid of sharing what are you
afraid that if somebody finds out about
you or if you showed are you told that
people would judge you for it and you
would be seen as a weak person what is
that thing identify keep it in your head
write it down what are you afraid to be
shown to be exposed for as a
weak person what's the first thing that
comes to mind
step number two share it with your close
family and friends share with people who
you think will support you don't share
with somebody who's gonna hate on you
you know if your mom always hates on
your ideas and don't share it with her
share with somebody who you know will
support you share with somebody who will
not judge you as being weak but will
actually see that as a strength that you
are willing to share that with them
because I don't want you to do is start
building up some momentum I want you to
feel like this is okay to share I want
you to feel the strength that you get
when you release this thing because the
more you speak it out the more you get
it out of your system the less control
and less power that it has over you
where if you're only talking in your
head if you never share if you're always
afraid of judgment then this thing that
you're afraid of being seen as weak for
it will own you for the rest of your
life it will own you you need to get out
of your system and so you start with
your close friends and family and step
number three now you're gonna share it
on Facebook you can share on Facebook or
Twitter or YouTube or Instagram or
wherever you're actually afraid of
putting it up because people are gonna
judge you forth now it's time you've
identified it in your head this is the
thing that you are afraid of being
exposed to being week four you need to
conquer this thing this will own you for
the rest of your life and left you do
too you build up some positive momentum
by sharing with some close friends and
family who you know will support you who
will say you've just been silly you have
to share that by used telling me it's
inspiring now I want to go off and do
something and then step number three you
put a public the more you share and not
to get in somebody's face and say this
is what you need to do you're not
preaching you're just sharing the more
you share the less control that thing
has over you and the more you're gonna
inspire other people to go off and own
their life as well now I've got a really
special bonus clip that I think you're
gonna enjoy but before that question
today I want to know here we go we're
gonna do the own your life formula
together right now instant action I want
to know what is the thing that you are
so afraid to share weakness in let's go
it's time to release it put in the
comments below
nice is way undervalued you know
particularly in this day and age you
know if you turn on the news everything
seems like it's gonna get blown up right
being nice just makes life so much
easier and look I learned the hard way I
had to have my partner Todd came to me
one day and he goes I like to curse he
goes I don't care about cursing but you
curse too much not everybody is as
accepting as cursing as you are calm
down and I took that to heart not so
much the cursing part but but I just I
it became apparent to me that the nicer
I got the more effective people around
me got the more productive they got the
more sales we had I was undervaluing
nice you know I started my my first
company after I got fired from a job and
I was 24 just turned 24 my first real
company if you will and I was always go
go go go go all consumed right live it
eat it sleep and breathe it and I knew
people couldn't keep up or work as hard
as many hours as me but I wanted them to
and we were successful and we didn't
have much turnover but I could have done
a better job if I were nicer and
broadcast calm I got a little bit nicer
right as things but then once I got to
the Mavs and and some of these other
companies and Todd reminded me you know
and and really told me you know just
nice nice works and so when you find
yourself going to work when you're
finding yourself dealing with customers
when you're finding yourself making
decisions we all get that ah jatai right
that feeling in our stomach that
tenseness that stress at various points
of times that we all have to go through
but sometimes you just need to calm down
right take a deep breath and be nice
because you'll find out that people will
do much more but if you reduce the
stress of people and you're nice you're
gonna have such a huge advantage no
matter what your technology is no matter
how it compares even if it's a download
for an app people will still have to
deal with you your culture will come
through being nice being being
supportive reducing stress that all
comes through even
when I worked for other companies some
of them not mentioning names were so bad
they would treat people the old way I'm
the boss here's what you're gonna do
because I'm the boss right or there were
times for example when maybe had a
dollar for lunch II can't get a lot for
a dollar so I just knew that that's how
I was and if I had a company that I had
a control of my gosh
everyone's gonna be treated the way I
wanted to be treated so the minute we
could afford it everyone had free lunch
whether you had money or not you have
free lunch we pay for it for you car
pool will pay for that so we started
doing things for people that I wish
happened to me maybe that's part of fate
maybe because a lot of things along the
way weren't so good that as things
started getting good it was so easy for
me to share with our people so easy to
do that people sometimes don't save
money as soon as we possibly could
afford it we started profit sharing
where at the end of every year and we'll
take that profit sharing and put in a
retirement fund for you it's yours it's
yours if you're so many years it goes
with you no matter where you go but it's
yours it's your money that's really
incredible
and how much do you think that that sort
of Golden Rule approach has fed into
your ridiculously low turnover rate
which is literally almost unprecedented
I mean that's crazy
I try and treat people exactly the way
they'd want to be treated exactly the
way I would have wanted to be treated
I'm happy with my people I realized my
people aren't the company if my people
go my god the company goes people are
your company and they take care of the
customer the customer is always right no
matter what so what do we do so the
customers happier if somebody's unhappy
would try and discover why and because
you treat people this way and we'd love
them you walk in our company it's love
if you go to the front desk here in
Century City this girl just has the
biggest smile say hi welcome to John
Paul Mitchell Systems she loves what she
does our big problem is we don't have
turnover we have so many people want to
work for us and the thing is you gotta
wait for somebody to die Najma girl
we'll add one or two on obviously at a
time sure and we're pretty big now
because we're in 96 countries it's how
you take care of people anywhere in the
world you don't boss them around you
include them what you're doing if you
want some intense
dwayne johnson motivation check out the
video right next to me i think you'll
enjoy it continue to believe and i'll
see you there
i did a lot of my growing up in Hawaii
and all my years of struggling that's
family I was evicted out of Hawaii we
were picked it out of our little
efficiency